well joining me here in studio is the
father alhaj Ali he's the special Envoy
for the president of the transitional
Sovereign Council in Sudan special Envoy
good to have you with us on Al Jazeera
I'm pleased to be with you Sohail thank
you for we talk about the politics
can we just talk about you as a citizen
of Sudan you are a resident you have
family and friends you've got your
people fighting each other your capital
in Ruins what goes through your mind
when you see those TV pictures that
we're all seeing at the moment and that
we have been seeing for what nearly
seven weeks now
that causes a lot of pain in in any
fellow citizen in Sudan
because gross violations of
international humanitarian law gross
violations for Vienna convention
this Rebellion
which started more than a month against
the state
they do not respect
peace and security
they are targeting civilians they are
causing a lot of harm
that's the politics there I'm talking
about you as a Sudanese citizen when you
see those pictures yourself
as an individual what are you thinking
because you've got friends and family in
the country as well I'm sure
well it makes me cry without tears
because any harm caused not only to my
family but every Sudanese is
unacceptable and it causes a lot of harm
to us what concerned us is the safety of
our city of of our citizens all over
Sudan so let's talk about the ceasefire
that's been ongoing for a week if we can
say ceasefire inverted commas there have
been violations on both sides according
to Independent reports we're coming to
just a few hours before that ceasefire
ends what's the situation at the moment
will that ceasefire in your opinion be
extended are there new terms being
negotiated or will the ceasefire just
end what's your understanding at the
moment before I give you a clear answer
about your question
relate regarding the ceasefire and the
possibility of expanding or extending
the Sohail is always good to call us pay
the speed it is not the two sides it's a
legal government against a rebellion in
the country the legal government
represented in the Sudanese Armed Forces
which is the legal institutions instruct
in entrusted to establish peace and
security according to the dictates of
the national Constitution
performing their duties
while the other side unfortunately
always the media agencies call them the
two sides or the equating the state the
state of Sudan or the country of and the
government of Sudan with the Rebellion
is unfair so yeah well you will call it
a rebellion sir because you're speaking
on behalf of the transitional Sovereign
Council of Sudan but there is a war
going on between two sides whoever they
are as you know a government and and a
special rapid security force and at the
end of the day you've got to try and
find a way of talking to each other to
find a way forward and that's what
Sudanese people want right now and at
the moment the most pressing issue is
the ceasefire so where are we with the
season it is true when you say there is
a war going on between
the government of Sudan and this
Rebellion Force but who started the war
uh it is it was this rapid deployment
Rebellion Force which has fired the
ferris bullet now I will come to the
ceasefire
we are very concerned
with the security and peace of our own
fellow citizens this is a priority in
our policy Whenever there is a chance to
extend
the ceasefire we will not hesitate a
second but unfortunately we have agreed
the first time the second time
five times but next day it was the
Rebellion Force which violates the
ceasefire and they commit gross
violations
the Americans and the Saudis have been
involved in negotiating this latest
seven-day ceasefire are they involved
again and at what level in terms of the
conversation with you or with the rsf
the initiative the bilateral initiative
of Saudi Arabia and the United States is
still going on regarding the ceasefire
and they are engaging with us on this
issue as I said
as soon as this ceasefire which will end
tonight we are ready we are ready but
our message to the facilitators or to
the initiators of this initiative they
should exercise
pressure on the other side on the
Rebellion
to make them respect and commit to the
agreement of Israel we should see what
happens in the coming hours
Ali special Envoy of the president of
the transitional Sovereign Council in
Sudan thank you for joining us here on
Al jazeer thank you Israel